[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 130 of
the Winkley Google cloud platform
podcast I'm mark mantle and I'm here
with my colleague as always Melanie
Warwick Melanie how are you doing today
doing good mark are you I'm very very
well yet another week yet another
podcast another podcast 130 hundredths
it's a good 20 and we'll be at 150 yes
math is good all right mark so this week
we have two wonderful women who have
joined us to talk about data science
pipelines and tools so Juliet and
Michelle are but with us and Juliet is
actually the Data Platform lead over at
stitch fix and Michelle is one of our
colleagues who works with us here at
Google does a lot of great things around
machine learning and Google cloud
platforms so before we get into that as
always we were going to talk about our
cool things of the week and our question
of the week is that if I have written AG
RPC service but I'm using a language
platform that isn't supported is there
any way I can access it as rest I wonder
where this question came from I don't
know maybe me maybe someone who is
hacking on it this weekend anyway so who
get to that question in a minute but
before that some of the cool things of
the week I'm gonna start with the fact
that Sandeep Dinesh who is one of our
colleagues on the team he's been doing
this great video series that video logs
video blogs video something sure so he's
been doing this series under the name of
kubernetes best practices and he
recently published the last episode in
his seven part series and so we will
include that in the show notes and the
last episode is upgrading your cluster
with zero downtime so if you've got a
cluster how do you get that updated and
you don't have to really spend any
effort and there's a great photo of him
in the video pointing at the camera
that's right it's just a great photo
it's good job ya know and he's got all
of the videos that he's done on the
subject are really wonderful so if you
haven't seen it you have questions about
kubernetes and work with containers you
should watch them yes they're really
good I want to send a shout out and
congratulations to the helm project helm
is a package managed solution for
kubernetes they recently have been voted
to be accepted into the cloud native
compute foundation as an incubation
level hosted project so congratulations
CNF yeah
translations to Talam I could say how
man seems yeah so the other thing we
were going to mention for this week is
that Android P is in beta this is the
next release of android and they've got
some great new features that are going
on that have to do with it you know
adaptive efficiencies within the Android
operating system in general like
prioritizing battery power for the apps
that you're using the most or in terms
of the brightness and and trying to
adapt the brightness of your device so
it's more efficient works longer works
better some of the cool things that they
mention are things like app actions
trying to determine what actual actions
you're taking with the app and like
bringing up adaptively what you might
want based on your previous whatever you
just opened or whatever you just were
looking at before I go to bed for
example I set my alone so I'm guessing
it's gonna show me my alarm quickly or
it's something they said was like if you
connect your headphones to the device
and you typically bring up Spotify that
it will more quickly identify your
Spotify playlist for you stuff like that
which i think is great anything that
makes it go faster and easier anyway so
that's available in beta yep and
somewhat self-serving Lee the ago news
project that I work on is gonna have a
0.2 release it should be out today the
release candidates out already but
literally I think as this thing gets
released either very shortly after or
very quickly for one or two other 0.2 it
should be out so they'll have speaking
of how I'm actually helped a king which
is lovely and fleet management and we're
also moving to a six-week release cycle
as well and one day we will do a podcast
about calm yeah I know you've been
bugging me about it we have some plans
we're gonna do it plans we have some
plans one day one day last thing we're
gonna mention and we'll include in the
show notes is there is a nice blog post
out about securing cloud connected
devices with cloud IOT and microchip and
this goes a little bit to this idea of
like the you be keys but it's a
microchip that you can use and helping
you to in essence secure the devices
without taking up too much memory
without having to do any remote uploads
or downloads it's it's a better way to
secure your IO T's from the various
hacking that can happen fancy yeah so
yeah great details in the article will
include it and you can check it out
mark shall we go talk to Juliet and
Michelle I think we should let's do it
this week's podcast we are excited to
have with us two wonderful data science
X
firts we have Michelle Casman who's one
of our colleagues and we have Juliet
Hoagland who is from stitch fix and
thank you both for coming on the podcast
it's great to be here thanks for having
us yeah thanks for having us
so Michelle can you start off by telling
us a little bit about yourself and what
you do at Google
sure I'm fairly new to the team I joined
the gcpd Braille team as an engineer and
I split my time between advocating for
the open source community of Q flow
that's machine learning on kubernetes as
well as data proc which is our managed
yarn service manage SPARC on yarn here
so my role is really to operate in the
space between internal developers and
external developers and try to make the
experience better for people using our
tools externally and also bringing that
feedback to our internal product teams
and making those better great and Juliet
I know you're the data platform
engineering manager over at stitch fix
can you tell us a little bit about what
you're doing and in your background sure
so I'm a data platform engineering
manager you're one yes the team that I
manage does workflow environment and
execution so what does it mean to run a
job on our infrastructure what does it
mean to schedule it run it reliably
build images that you're gonna be
running these things in a lot of this
infrastructure exists but what we're
working towards now is having a more
unified easy-to-use interface for it and
having it hang together and so in my
background is a mixture of data science
and engineering since grad school I've
sort of switched between heavy
engineering and heavy data science jobs
and I like being somewhere in that
interface and building good tools for
data scientists so I'm pretty excited to
be working at stitch fix building good
tools for data scientists great yes and
I know today we wanted to get into data
science what it is what it means as well
as talk about some of the tooling around
that and what you're using so to kick us
off how do you define data science sure
so stitch fix has a department called
algorithms and analytics and the
algorithms and analytics department is
vertically oriented meaning we work with
styling we work with clients we work
with merchandising and operations like
our warehouse operations and the data
scientists on our team do a variety of
things
but try to enable and optimize the
business through using data well and we
err on the side of trying to do that
programmatically and automatically as
opposed to having one of our business
partners come to a data scientist and
say hey like I have this question and
build me a report so a lot of what our
data scientists do is try to build
systems and levers into the business
that help the business run more
efficiently and optimize it so a great
example is you know warehouse routing
optimization of how do people that are
picking items like meaning clothing off
of racks walk through the warehouse to
minimize the distance right so that's
not a definition but that's how we
practice it right and I've seen
different companies have different
definitions for what that means for them
so Michelle how do you define data
science yeah I feel like this is one of
the most loaded questions that I ever
get like yet so my background has also
been heavy engineering started out with
computer science degrees and kind of
gone back and forth between data science
official data science roles and official
engineering roles and there's been a lot
of variability in those roles but the
same person and mostly the same skillset
for all the different titles and all the
different responsibilities so I feel
like exactly as you said every company
has their own definition of it and and
it's kind of grown organically I'm it's
still like a fairly young field
and going through especially data
science interviews are one of the most
confusing things to prepare for because
of those differing definitions and the
different expectations I feel like it's
definitely blending more into there's
less of a differentiation between data
engineering and data science mostly I
feel like it's just an umbrella term and
it's a way for people to describe hey
there's this magical thing that I want
to happen and I need people with math
skills with engineering skills people
who can actually build something to
solve a particular problem but yeah
there's a lot of contention in this area
and and specifically I feel like it it
kind of fuels the fire of like data
science versus engineering that I think
is kind of counterproductive so I'm
going to like decline from giving a
specific definition yeah well and I
think even within what you're describing
I've heard data science decompose into
three areas of data science where you
have inference and a/b testing you have
decision science like how do you
to some sort of business conclusion or
decide what a business should do and
then you also have the sort of machine
learning engineering building automatic
systems type of data science and so I
think those are three categories of what
data scientists do that require
different skill sets and experience and
you can get deep in any of them and what
you're describing with engineering I
think all of them benefit from
engineering but some have better tooling
already and some don't decision signs an
inference I think have relatively good
tooling in existence whereas the machine
learning engineering the tooling is kind
of lacking and new yeah that's true and
it requires a lot more engineering in
order to enable that area yeah
definitely you mentioned there's tooling
what sort of tooling does exist for
those areas that you particularly fond
of I mean it's getting better over the
years
but it's been pretty lacking I guess
traditionally the the decision science
tools things like SAS MATLAB things that
are more heavy on the math side but
actually putting those into production
systems we've kind of seen a shift from
like traditional software engineering
tools that have been sort of adapted
over the years to things that are more
specific to do science I guess in the
past I've seen things like informatica
just data forklifting tools back-end
systems like tera data that try and
solve the distributed computing up to
like today the biggest shift I've seen
in the space is with kubernetes and
being able to take a lot of those very
specific problems and run them in a
single environment that's where I've
seen a big shift from these sort of very
specific data science tools solving one
specific problem into a more
general-purpose fitting more into that
traditional software development role
where you have all these pieces that can
interact together in a repeatable way
and you can deploy it and you can be
confident that that code hasn't changed
and that things haven't changed in
between and you can be a lot more robust
and sort of adopt those traditional soft
development practices into more of the
data science machine learning space yeah
I've seen I think there's a ton of
different tools out there at different
levels of the data stack right there's a
ton of new data processing libraries
that run on people's machines so
so I could learn has been around for a
while but it like actually boost is
getting a huge amount of traction things
like pi torch and tensorflow huge amount
of traction those are booming and they
often require specialized hardware but
that brings up the question of once you
have these programs running and a data
scientist built some sort of model that
works on their laptop that's not
production they need to be able to
actually use the infrastructure that we
have and put these things on a some sort
of schedule and know where these certain
attacks executed and in what environment
and so there's a huge amount of tooling
around how do you take something that
works on someone's laptop and make it
robust reliable scheduled and I think
things like kubernetes or at stitch fix
we have a system called flotilla which
is used for defining a job and what that
job might look like and so a job has a
docker image it has a run command it has
environment variables things like that
and beyond this job definition you also
want schedule and once you have
scheduling you have to begin to think
about well this is not one person
scheduling something this is actually a
variety of teams that have a variety of
needs and they're all sharing a resource
and you begin to pretty quickly get into
queues and scheduling and what it means
for having some sort of fair share
between different teams on cluster
resources that we have and so things
that have been solved on supercomputers
then solved in resource managers you end
up beginning to think about your own
systems so I think there's lots of
different places in the stack where new
tools exist some of these can be data
access to data processing tools sequel
has been around in forever at least in
computer years and beyond that you know
there's tons of larger scale data
processing tools stitch fix we don't
frequently have to use them we do have a
spark cluster we use it for a variety of
things but it's pretty rare for our data
scientists to build models that are
distributed but we do have if you count
all of our data together a large amount
of data that people are moving kind of
all over the place there's a lot of
different tools that interlock but I
would say there's data access and client
libraries and then cluster resource
scheduling kind of tools that people can
actually use it in our cloud
infrastructure
I know Juliette you're talking about how
data science has seen it stitch fix
would you also say that your data
platform engineering is that consent is
more like data engineering is that also
classified under the data science
umbrella how do you guys partner the way
that
data science and Data Platform interact
at stitch fix is that we expect data
scientists to own their workflows end to
end and this is pretty unique because a
lot of companies have data engineers
that hook up the pipes and make sure the
data is getting to the right place in
the right formats the data scientists
can do their modeling and we think that
there's something that you trade in a
system like that what you're trading is
the data will get there reliably in
whatever format it gets there but then
there's this interaction and handoff
where I did assigned this will model
something and they realized that the
pipeline needs to be changed and so they
go back to the data engineer and say hey
you need to go fix this thing you need
to change the format and we don't want
handoff like that a lot of stitch fixed
data science is stitch fix algorithms in
general is really focused on autonomy
and ownership and we design the
organization for quick iteration on
models and that means not having handoff
between data platform and data science
and so the reason that we're on the data
platform are not data engineers is that
we build tools to allow data scientist
to be self-service and to be independent
in owning their workflows and so it's
pretty different model than a lot of
companies and one of the reasons I think
it's pretty interesting to work there
building tools yeah I feel like that
approach is really pioneering I didn't
really know a whole lot about that but
sort of independently arrived at
something very similar at the previous
company that I worked for that sort of
enablement and empowering all of your
engineers and data scientists to be able
to deploy their own stuff from
conception from the very beginning all
the way through to production and then
to iterate on that that saves so much
time and not having that handoff not
having that human interaction and like
having asked for permission and being
added to a pipeline or a queue like
managing that human resource side of
things I felt like that was very
transformative in just being able to
iterate on models so much more quickly
and not having them get stale not having
them be sort of out of date already by
the time they make it to production I'm
that one ership and that empowerment is
really critical I feel like you guys
have such a huge custom sort of
hand-built architecture you but you have
your own system that manages all that
that that supports that but I also think
that it's it's something like for me
kubernetes really enabled that and it's
also something that you don't need an
entire team to do for you like I feel
like the tools are there in order to
enable that process and you don't have
to be like a sophisticated
data science institution in order to do
that what do you think are some of the
bigger challenges in this space I think
in our particular situation this
self-service model it is good in a
variety of ways but there are obvious
drawbacks and sort of trade-offs right
when experience data engineers are the
ones building the pipelines then you're
gonna have more robust pipelines and so
trying to figure out systems and tooling
to make it easier to build robust
pipelines in our case is definitely a
big challenge how do we allow data
scientist to be self-service and still
sort of push them in the direction of
highest quality possible-- and highest
reliability possible and that's a
problem that's specific to us but when I
think about problems in general that a
lot of people are facing and thinking
about scheduling complex workflows and
versioning complex workflows I think
having reproducibility of models is very
related to being able to understand
where data came from and where model
artifacts or dashboards came from and
what definitions are being used and this
is a pretty common problem that ends up
being talked about and by the hallway
track of conferences right people at
data engineering conferences will begin
to discuss issues that they have and
often will be oh this open source
project is always falling over or what
is this data and where did it come from
and how do you go about providing that
visibility to users yeah I feel like the
larger story is the the sort of dirty
secret of his science just because
people really want to talk about the
algorithms themselves and what cool
techniques they're using but I feel like
the bigger problem and the the place
where people spend more time is just on
the system as a whole and not that one
machine learning component I feel like
that's a much smaller piece and
stitching all those pieces together is a
non-trivial problem for reproducibility
sake for interpretability sake for being
able to actually trace back here's a
result that we got but where did it come
from and how did we arrive on that there
are a lot of reasons why you might want
to know that the other challenge I see
is just getting things from that sort of
experimental phase into production
without having a whole lot of things
change in between so being able to like
work locally and then transform that
into something running on a dev cluster
and that into production and being able
to make sure that it's the same model
that was intent
by the first person who first built it
and and that whole empowerment and being
able to deploy your own models I feel
like really helps to dissolve that does
that word tools like using something
like kubernetes cue flow to be able to
help with reproducibility as well as
moving it from local to global would
potentially come in exactly yeah that's
a big idea behind cue flow it supports
the whole machine learning application
so as a single unit instead of trying to
deploy lots of different pieces in lots
of different places the idea behind it
is essentially to take that entire
application so not just the ml but the
logging the monitoring the front-end all
of the auditing all of the versioning
everything packaging up into one place
and being able to run that locally for
yourself being able to access that
through like a Jupiter hub I'm so having
other people access it in a in a single
kubernetes cluster but then being able
to take that exact same code you need a
couple environment commands and run it
in the cloud in a different cloud on a
completely different set of physical
hardware or on-prem or any combination
of that that's it's meant to solve that
problem so I think that gets at a large
part of the reproducibility problem of
the environment and the code that you're
running but one of the biggest
challenges that I've seen in any type of
statistical learned model is the data
part the thing that makes these sort of
systems challenging and it for
reproducibility is the tight coupling
between the data that you're using like
what data do did you use to build this
model or what data is it expecting in
and what kind of statistical
distribution is it good at producing
predictions for and there's a tight
coupling there and I think that systems
that help with the environment and help
with the software are a piece of it but
trying to understand that the connection
to the data that is actually being used
is a big big challenge and it's not
something that is solved in a way that
the industry in general can point to and
be like oh yes this is the industry best
practice this is some that everyone
talks about and doesn't have a good
solution to as far as I have heard yeah
so I've seen a couple of tools come up
pretty recently that I haven't tried out
cue flow supports one of them one I
think is pachyderm and then another is
quilt data and both of them I've looked
into them but just haven't use them in a
production capacity and
they're trying to solve that exact
problem I've only looked at pachyderm
and I really like the idea behind it but
it's version of data versioning is very
heavyweight from what I saw what do you
do is you bring your data into a
container and then you version it there
and so basically pachyderm works but
only if everything is inside this
universe of pachyderm mmm I see and I
see that is very heavyweight and not
something that people can easily adopt
in systems that exist already
interesting and perhaps if you're
building something new like brand new
mm-hmm or you're willing to sort of make
that sacrifice and move entirely into
that type of system does heavyweight but
I haven't dug deeper into actually using
it yeah I'd be interested to hear how
stitch fix solves that problem in the
future well and I actually was gonna ask
that in terms of I know you don't know
exactly what the best practices are this
is something people are trying to go
after what are some best practices or
ways that you guys are trying to
approach these types of problems for
reproducibility that you think would be
good to see others attempt or at least
as useful for your group so we're
thinking about it in terms of
decomposing the problem first into data
versioning and then artifact versioning
so what is this data and how did it get
here what is this process that generated
and this ends up being very deeply
linked to data lineage and so data
lineage I think of as this table and
this partition was the input here is a
process or a job that is the thing that
used that input and you maybe have a
collection of inputs right and then the
output is a table columns partitions
that this thing gets written to and so
you have some sort of you need some sort
of meta information that says this is
the link between these tables and this
is the version of the job that ran so
you version the job and you version the
data and so that's one way that we're
beginning to look at this that was
actually a project I was working on
before I started managing this team and
I've decided to put it on the back
burner until this team is I feel more
comfortable in my role basically
understandable but once that is in place
I think you need good data versioning
before you get model versioning and
model versioning I think is a Holy Grail
that many companies would like to have
you would think many companies could say
that like oh yes I know what this model
is I know it went into it and I think
you would be wrong
in almost all of them
I've definitely heard rumors of certain
types of models that you would think
would be very resilient and robust not
being reproducible and having no way of
recreating them a disk drive were to
fail for example I'm sure they're you
know replicating them we actually had
the team the folks here working at
project Jupiter here a few weeks back
and we talked about you know
reproducibility is one of the goals for
some of the things that they're building
out as well that they know that that's a
clear problem that's going on in general
but you know that the effort to try to
solve for that well I think isn't being
really related so why do people do data
science I'd say some people do data
science to say that they are right
there's some companies that are like ooh
yeah this is our AI strategy right and
some people do data science because they
want to deliver value to a business and
if what you're trying to do is deliver
value to a business you need to have
credibility you need to be able to
clearly explain yourself to business
partners and have them believe that what
you've made is useful and for that you
might not need the holy grail version of
model visibility and versioning and
reproducibility but you need some level
of reliability and clarity about what
you've made and I think it's very easy
in data systems to end up with a mess
that is unexplainable just so people who
aren't as familiar with data science get
them understanding what do you mean by
model versioning what does that mean
let's say you have a linear regression
model you can build it once you have
some data you fit it and it knows how to
predict think it's really great I have
my model right in a real production
system you have this code that generates
the model you have the data that went
into it and what you need to do is apply
that code that knows how to train a
model and get the parameters to new data
and so there's maybe two types of
versioning here there's a model that
gets trained again and you get a new
collection of fit parameters but the way
that you've trained it hasn't changed
and so you probably want to version that
and understand what data went in to
create these parameters and then let's
say you want to add another feature this
is now different code and a different
structure of a model in a different way
you've done training and even if you
applied to the same data it's a
different model and so there's two types
of versioning there one is that the way
you're producing the model and the
structure of the model is stayed the
same but the data is new and the other
is the structure of the model has
changed perhaps also
and those are two types of versioning
that you probably want to track and
often it's just sort of like very easy
ways to not do bottle versioning and to
not keep track of that which will bite
you later
especially when you end up trying to get
into he make a model is it any better
you need to do a B testing how do you
set up a system that can do a/b testing
how do you know what went into the two
models that you're comparing what the
difference is we were chatting offline a
little bit about the tooling juliette
that I know your group is using can you
explain a little bit about the type of
setup especially for the data scientist
types of tools that you're you're
setting up with them for them to be able
to do the work that they're doing so we
have cloud infrastructure and we allow
data scientists to specify jobs jobs are
defined as docker containers running on
a cluster so this job will be submitted
on a particular cluster and these jobs
are specified through an open-source
tool we have called flotilla so flotilla
is fantastic it's super self-service our
data scientists all really like it and
we actually just did a survey of the
data platform tools and got information
from the data scientist and we asked
like what tool would you miss the most
40% said flotilla which is great and so
flotilla allows data scientists to use a
UI to say I want to use this docker
image this is the command I want to run
here are some environment variables that
often people will use to define a git
repo that they want to pull from and a
branch they want to use and then we have
a scheduling system that integrates with
that and that scheduling system says
combine like make this dag of jobs and
run it every day at midnight or the
first step of this dag is wait for data
to appear and once this data appears
then run the rest of this workflow and
so that ends up being what our
self-service ETL definition and
scheduling system looks like and data
scientists are pretty happy with that
workflow we have tools that are somewhat
custom for building docker images
because it came from world where we
needed to build rpms machine images and
docker images where that is a little
harder to use for our data scientists so
we're thinking of ways that we can make
that simpler use more open source tools
hopefully just give them docker files to
define
I like it Michelle from your work in the
past would have been some of the
pipeline's that you've seen or what are
some ones that are successful from your
perspective so I was working for a
company called Cordoba previously it's a
start-up based here in San Francisco and
it's essentially a b2b SAS platform with
machine learning components and so there
was sort of the normal sort of back-end
web component of like what you would
normally consider like a typical web
architecture typical micro-services
architecture and then when we added the
machine learning components to that they
looked very different they didn't have
that sort of standard you know thousands
of companies have already built an
architecture that looks just like this
there are these weird machine learning
components that are we're kind of trying
to tack on to that and the way we solve
that problem is to take things from this
very homogenous platform and put it all
into a managed kubernetes environment
where we can run everything together
because it's essentially one application
it's one cohesive platform for users and
by putting that all in the same place we
were able to utilize these very
different resource requirements but have
everything in sort of a self-contained
single manageable space that you could
wrap your head around and then also
enable the person writing the machine
learning code to also deploy all the way
through to production and iterate very
easily but even that still required
specific docker containers for each one
of those components for the ingress for
back-end for search for the feature
ization components for data for all of
that and that took a while to build out
and it ran very smoothly once it was in
place but I took a lot of what I learned
from that experience and it really I
don't want to underscore the fact that
it just really transformed the DevOps
experience at that company like it took
what was a very onerous sort of just
kind of scattered thing things were in
lots of different places and it just put
it into this one little neatly packaged
collection a place you could really
operate on much more easily and and
standardize across all of the different
pieces but I took a lot of what I
learned there
I'm applying that now to building this
this cute flow project and the idea is
the same where you have all of these
different pieces of a machine learning
application and you want them all in one
place because you want to be able to
version them you want to be able to move
them from one environment to the other
and iterate through during the
development process and do that in a way
that scales and as new hardware comes
out I think you guys talked recently
about like new VMs that came out was
just ridiculous amounts of RAM and CPU
and being able to to not have to change
your code but still be able to utilize
those and basically just deploy it to a
new cluster a big piece of that was just
using managed services instead of doing
everything from scratch like originally
I believe Cordoba was sort of rolling
their own open source frameworks on on
VMs and managing that independently and
that was that took a lot of a lot of
people hours it took a lot of sort of
babysitting and by switching to manage
kubernetes
a lot of that went away a lot of the
network headaches the like hard-coded IP
addresses a lot of that just sort of
dissolved into some of the features that
you get from a managed code editing
environment so the aim of queue flow is
to really take all of the the benefits
everything that kubernetes does really
well and sort of apply that to a machine
learning application so that's sort of
where I see the future of machine
learning heading is into this
declarative way of defining your
application and you just sort of define
the resources that you need for each
piece and then you're less tied to the
physical hardware that it's running on
you can just say hey I want GPUs for
this piece you have all the different
types of hardware all in the same
cluster and you don't really have to
think about it and kubernetes and queue
flow manages that for you nice coming
back a little bit too when we're talking
about the challenge of reproducibility
do you have any perspective on what can
make people feel confident and what is
being used now for models like if it's
hard to reproduce is it just well we
just have to believe that that it's fine
and move forward or I find that most
people just don't question it right
there's this blind faith that like oh
this is mathematical this is analytical
it must be correct it must be true and I
you think they should question more
well they should consider question
anymore I think that business partners
that are coming from less of an
analytical data science background have
their own questions and are often too
easily convinced by this analytical this
is mathematical it must be true i
similarly think the data science
practitioners also get kind of caught up
in that mode of thinking that this is
analytical this is mathematical it must
be true right and really effective data
scientists that I've seen tend to
question more and tend to sort of work
in a simpler mode so that they can
circle back on that question of am i
building something valuable am i making
something correct is this something
believable because once you get into the
technical nitty-gritty and built a
complex model it's easy to convince
yourself that oh the ROC is good and so
I'm not gonna worry about it yeah yeah
we did a podcast on machine learning
bias and fairness a while back too I
think that definitely plays we're all
here to you don't want to just blindly
follow that this model is fine there's
not great automated tools for it right
like this is why data scientists data
science practitioners with a lot of
experience that are thoughtful about
what they're building are really
valuable they'll take a step back and
they'll think about having made
something good have I made something
that this business will find valuable
for a long time meaning is reproducible
is explainable so to that point if you
had sort of a magic wand or either you
had a magic wand where you're like this
is the tool that I would love to have
right now and I could just make it with
this magic wand what would you make I
mean I would love something that just
spit out the right model every time all
the development worked for me like this
is what your future ization pipeline
should look like these are all the hyper
parameters you should have that would be
amazing I mean I think we're working
towards we're trying to provide that a
lot of the managed service as the point
is give us your data and and we'll try
and fit the best model for you I mean
that seems pretty magical and like that
day is not quite here yet but I feel
like we're making steps towards that I
would say a sort of listener in a data
science environment that watches what
steps the data scientist takes and sort
of automatically makes a lab notebook
every good scientist has a lab notebook
where they're making notes about the
environment they're in their experiments
our setups would have happened that day
I think something that is
made it that watches and sort of
generates a lab notebook for data
scientists would be my dream I actually
was at a conference last week where on
disaster risk recovery and I noticed one
of the key things that was really a
challenge for these organizations that
are trying to understand and anticipate
in plan and analyze for potential
natural disasters is just asking the
right question like what is the real
problem you can try to solve with
technology to be able to apply it it
would be great if you just had something
I could spit out the model like I think
what is the real question and then what
is the tech in the the model that I
should be using for that question so
previously I had worked at Cloudera
and I did data science there and I would
occasionally go out to big customers and
to talk with them about their data
science problems so once I went out to a
large customer and they have call
centers and so what they had done was
they had transcribed calls to their call
centers and so they now had text for
instead of voice and so they brought me
in because they're like well we have
this small five person analytics team
and we would like for them to build an
NLP model which will do entity
identification entity resolution and
from these call logs pick out pieces of
information that are valuable to us
because they had resources and customers
were calling for these resources and
they were only tracking it if they had
the resources they could give them but
they wanted to understand what the
demand was that they're missing right
and so I talked with them for a bit and
I realized that their team does not have
the skills to build an NLP model like
that nor is usually building a model
that complex really the answer and so I
talked to them for a while and I
realized that what they wanted was to
get the structured information that the
call center representatives were already
listening to and putting into a form
that was getting turned into a single
query that that hit their databases and
so hearing that I suggested that instead
of transcribing their voice to text and
then building a very complex set of
stacked and all P models that perhaps
what they could do is instead keep the
database queries and they had spent
already a lot of
and many months on this project and they
were a little taken aback but also
pretty excited that they weren't about
to waste a ton more the key part yeah
yeah I feel like at the beginning of
every project that is the number one
most crucial thing you can do is make
sure that you're asking the right
question and then like if you have the
right question in mind can you arrive at
the answer with something that's very
simple
and mathematically straightforward like
if the answer to that is no then try
machine learning but the the answer is
not machine learning and you certainly
shouldn't start a company based on like
I'm going to do these stacked NLP models
or start a project with that as the goal
you really don't want to let technology
or techniques drive finding answers one
question I want to ask both of you what
do you enjoy most about data science and
data and general working with data I
like that it's always a challenge
there's so much to learn using data
effectively is a mixture of
understanding the technology available
to work with data understanding the
mathematical techniques available and
being able to communicate with people
and understand what the problem is in
general and I think that's third one
being the most important step because if
you just do the first two you end up
with things like transcribing voice into
text and building stacked NLP models but
you know knowing a little bit about web
applications and databases and then
understanding the problem is this person
is transcribing it like it kind of gives
you a good cut off in short cut and so I
would say that the part that I like the
best about working with data is needing
to constantly be improving your skills
on all three fronts and maybe that's a
bad way to phrase it
I tend to focus on improving my skills
on one of those fronts and then
switching between them over longer
periods of time I'm not constantly
trying to push myself in every direction
but always having ways to expand your
skill set technologically and
mathematically in terms of humans I
really enjoy that and the people are
great mostly mostly about it yeah I feel
like one of my favorite things is just
there is an infinite number of
directions to go in I feel like data is
something that seems so straightforward
it's it's it's pretty tangible it's a
thing that they should be well
understood because we've been working
with it for decades but every time I go
to solve what seems like a
straightforward
problem you just have so many so many
avenues to go down and it's like you can
go into just you can get on so many
different rabbit holes and and solve the
problem in so many different ways that
that it is very challenging and there's
never a shortage of new things to learn
of new ways to tackle a problem and
that's also like from a theoretical
perspective from a practical perspective
I never feel like there's a lack of
things to learn and ways to be
challenged and the the impact that you
can have with that like going in any
different direction just feels like you
can change the world in so many
different ways big or small that's most
exciting to me so any resources that
you'd recommend for those out there
interested in data science data
engineering machine learning I really
love the machine learning flashcards
that Chris Allen puts out those are my
favorite they're just these little hand
draw and like he'll have a formula that
he'll just draw out literally like you
would do in college and I think he
started out just making them for himself
but they're like 300 now and he
publishes them you can purchase them for
like 10 15 bucks but they're really
really good and just going through a few
of those a day just kind of refreshes
like keeps the neurons firing I really
like those it's not a place to start but
it is a good way it's a good resource
there's a lot of different things that
you can develop and you can learn and so
one of the best resources I've seen that
has a sort of hierarchy and structure of
the different types of things you could
be developing and learning is a website
called open source data science masters
oh is that Claire's website and that is
a really good resource yeah and so
there's a bunch of different topics in
there and I would say one of the most
overlooked skills for people coming from
a software background to data science is
linear algebra and so linear algebra is
the best start there it'll help you so
much yeah it's a really good
foundational like the stronger your
linear algebra foundations are the
easier machine learning is yeah this has
been great I know we're pretty much at a
time at this point but was there
anything else that you wanted to mention
before we wrap up any places that you'll
be speaking stitch fixes always hiring
and come work with us I hear it's a
great place to work
from many other people not just Juliet
but it is one of the places that has had
really from the beginning it was a data
science driven organization and it's
it's one of the most respected places to
work as a data scientist and I hear it
it's awesome to work for so many
wonderful women just like Juliet yes
definitely awesome thank you Michelle
that's great it's not getting paid for
this Michelle did you want to add
anything in your it I think our team is
also hired in developer relations like
but are you gonna be speaking anywhere
anytime soon I will be a docker con here
in SF in a few weeks that is June 12th
13th somewhere around there I'll be
doing a community session with J Smith
we'll be talking about cue flow and it's
kind of an unconference style it's like
a three hour session where we tell you a
little bit about cube flow there are a
couple of other open source projects
there as well and then we we talk about
what we want to work on next and kind of
some of the hot button issues in the
community please join the community if
you're interested in hearing more about
coop flow if you just google cube flow
you'll find there's were a github repo
cute little slash cute flow there's also
a mailing list I believe that's all on
there but if you go to github.com / qø /
community any of those links those will
lead you to our project we put them in
the show notes well thank you to both of
you for coming on the podcast today this
has been really great and a super
interesting interview thank you thanks
thanks again to Juliet and Michelle for
joining us today on the podcast super
interesting conversation talking about
data science pipelines and how all that
stuff gets built out agreed all right
mark
so question of the week yeah if I've
written a G RPC service but I'm using a
language or a platform that isn't
supported is there any way I can access
it as a rest yeah so I really like to
your FPC so if you're not familiar with
G RPC it stands for GRCC remote
procedure call
so it's recursive great always yeah
fantastic it's a great way of building
remote procedure call systems it does a
lot of really cool stuff one of the
things that's great about your RPC is it
sends things like pert our buffer over
the wire uses HTTP to so it has some
requirements and there's a set of
languages that are supported so if
you're using a language or a platform
that isn't supported like say maybe
JavaScript on the browser or maybe
there's a particularly
which hasn't been built for yet
something like that you can actually
expose it as rest and there's a couple
of tools that let you do that each with
its kind of pros and cons the one that
came out first yeah I'm gonna say it
came out first is an open-source product
that was in the GRP Sea ecosystem
repository called gr PC gateway it's
literally a tool and/or a library that
you can either do one of two ways if
you've got a G RPC service written as go
you can basically use it as a library to
expose your endpoints as HTTP you put
some extra configuration in your profile
and you can do it that way it'll also
generate swagger do some other and I
stuff too but it can also be used as a
proxy if you want to do it that way too
so if you have a GOP C service in a
different language or you just want to
put a proxy in front without having to
work in the same process you can do that
and that works really nicely the other
thing that is also possible is you can
use another proxy called envoi and boys
got a lot of popularity recently came
out of collaborations between lyft and
Google and probably a whole bunch of
other people as well it does a whole
bunch of stuff but one of the things it
can also do is also to G RPC conversions
to HTTP and JSON so essentially arrests
very much in exactly the same vein as
Jeff PC gateway does actually as well
which is kind of neat uses the same
configuration and finally should also
make mention of the fact that if you're
running on Google Cloud we have a
product called Cloud endpoints will
actually do exactly the same thing as
well so you can also use that to convert
from trpc2 HTTP endpoints and the neat
thing is all three of them use exactly
the same configuration so you can
actually try one I would say pretty much
switch between the others really
relatively easily we'll add some more
documentation to the show notes as well
that's great well thanks for that mark
so mark where you gonna be what am i
doing what's going on yeah you did your
talk actually how did it go that was fun
we had a good time I had a good chat
about how you can't just add more
servers but on the 14th of June I will
actually be presenting on organiz
speaking of which at the san francisco
kubernetes made up thanks I'll be there
chatting about that what are you getting
up to
I am slated to speak on June 26 at a
joint event by PI ladies and women in
machine learning a data science we're
going to be talking about path to data
science once I have more details on that
I'll add that in show notes awesome
fantastic well Melanie thank you for
once again joining me on the podcast
thank you Mark and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
no no no no they're not they're not done
it
[Laughter]